ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
SO COMMITTEE. WE ARE MISSING
THE CHAIRMAN IF YOU HAVEN'T
NOTICED HE IS OUT SICK SO WE
WISH HIM UP ON HELP HE'S BACK
WITH THE CENTER I WILL BE
CHAIRING THE COMMITTEE TODAY
WITH MEETING TOLD PLACE WITH
EXPLAINS THE LACK OF MEMBERS
HERE BUT WE DO HAVE A BILL OUT
THERE HERE HEY ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
HAND WISHES. BILL WHICH- THANK
NINETEEN AND WE WILL START AS
HE SAID COMMITTEE SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A YET SO IF YOU MIND.
FLOORS.
YEAH BUT THERE WE GO.
YOU MISSED THE BEST PART AB A
PRIORITY INCIDENT IS WHEN THE
APP OF PASSED RESULTING HUMAN
EXPOSURE INJURY ILLNESS OR
DAMAGE TO THE ENVIRONMENT THE
CURRENT VIOLATION CAPS FOR
THESE HARMFUL IT AND HAVE NOT
BEEN INCREASE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. AND DOESN'T CARRY THE
SAME PRACTICE CENTER BUT A ONE
HAD. NEED TO ENSURE THE RE
OFFENDERS AND BACK ACTORS THERE
FIRST. APPLY PESTICIDES ARE
PROPERLY HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONERS IN
DPR HAVE THE TOOLS TO DO SO. AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN WERE ALSO
AUTHORIZED. DISTANCE IN TAKING
ENFORCEMENT. IF THE
COMMISSIONERS LACK RESOURCES TO
PURSUE A VIOLATION IF THERE'S A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST OR IF THE
VIOLATION WAS COMMITTED IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ENGAGING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND MAKE
CERTAIN. BILL IS IN THE BEST
SHAPE ACT WORKERS AND- MOVIES
THAT ARE FIVE BY THESE. STAY
WITH ME IS AND PATENT DIRECTOR
FROM THE PESTICIDE AND WORK
SAFETY PROJECT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AFTERNOON I AM IN QUE
FOR CALIFORNIA LEGAL. FOUND
AND- OVER THE PAST THIRTY YEARS
I HAVE REVIEWED HUNDREDS OF
PRIORITY INVESTIGATIONS OF
PESTICIDE DRIFT. AND SPOKEN
WITH MANY FARMWORKERS AND OTHER
RULE RESIDENTS WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY THESE INCIDENTS- IS
DETAILED IN THE COMMITTEE
REPORT THERE ABOUT TWENTY SUCH
INCIDENTS PER YEAR. RESULT IN
SOME IN FOR AN ACT IN. THEN
THESE EPISODES- QUITE OFTEN
IMPACT DOZENS OF FIELD WORKERS
A RULE RESIDENTS AND IT'S NOT
AND IT IS AND SOMETIMES THE
IMPACT SEVERAL HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS. SOME COMMON IN
SEND SEND. DRIFT INCIDENTS IN
WOULD SEVERE. DIZZINESS NAUSEA.
NG DIFFICULTY BREATHING RASHES
AND EXTREME I PAYING YOUNG
CHILDREN THE ELDERLY AND PEOPLE
WITH A PRE EXISTING HEALTH
CONDITIONS ARE MOST SEVERELY
AFFECTED THESE EXPERIENCES ARE
TRAUMATIC FOR THOSE IMPACTED.
IN RESULT IN PERSISTING ANXIETY
AND PERSISTING SYMPTOMS SUCH AS
AGGRAVATED ASTHMA OR REACTIVE
AIRWAY THESE DISORDERS OR
PAINFUL RASHES THAT CAN BECOME
INFECTED. VICTIMS COLUSA
MULTIPLE DAYS OF WORK IN
SCHOOL- THESE INCIDENTS ALSO
OFTEN DISRUPT HARVEST WORK IN
COST CROP LOSS ON FARMS. THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY DRIFT FROM
NEIGHBORING OPERATION SO IT'S
COSTLY TO THE INDUSTRY ALSO- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT WILL FAR
TOWARDS BET TO SO FILE. AND THE
IMPACTS IN HARDSHIP THEY THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MUCH WE ARE
GOING TO JUST BRIEFLY SO WE
HAVE A NOW MADAM SO IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS TO
SCORE A- MELENDEZ. WHEN HERE
-ARAMBULA. BARRICADE HERE ARE
CAN HEAR. IT'S GOING TO GO TO
SEE A CRISTINA GARCIA HERE
WHOLE. MATHIS WHAT A TO G.
OBERNOLTE OVER HERE KALRA
COLORING WE HAVE A C<c.cyan>. A</c>
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT
ALSO WELCOME AS CALL WROTE AREA
ON THE AN WHO IS THE IN FOR
SOME LIMóN WE HAVE AB TWO ONE
OF WHICH IS ON THE CA. CALENDAR
ON WOULD LIKE COME. OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU. CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AB TWENTY ONE OH FOUR
BECAUSE GARCIA MELENDEZ HIGH
MELENDEZ I. -ARAMBULA ERICA I
CAN'T I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLD. MATHIS
WHAT A TO G. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I KALRA CORE I SO
THAT HAS BY. TRAFFIC OKAY THAT
BILL IS OUT NOW WE WILL ON USER
ANY WAY WISH TO. TESTIFY IN SO
OF THIS BILL IF YOU DO PLEASE
COME FORWARD. NOW IS IT. THANK
YOU. THE LOOK. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING A TEST FIND. IS THERE
ANY OP WAS TO COME IN TEST. DO.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CITY MUTUAL CAL
FRESH FOR ASSOCIATE WESTERN
HEALTH A COUPLE OTHER UP GROUPS
OF FIRST UP LIKE. THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS I'M IN APPRECIATION TO
THE VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS UP
PUT TOGETHER BY STAFF OUTLINING
THE HISTORY OF THIS ISSUE- AND
THE ELEMENTS THE LAW. AND ALSO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAFF AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SOME CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WARNING OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. CANNOT
ARGUE WITH ANY OF THE COMMENTS
OF THE AUTHOR I WHEN IT COMES
TO WANTING STRICT ENFORCEMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATIONS. AFTER
BAD ACTORS. WE DO AGREE WITH
ONE OF THE COMMENTS THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS AND WOULD LIKE TO JUST
SEE A MINOR TWEAKING THE
SUBSTANCE PORTION OF THE
LANGUAGE. BILLION WITH A MORE
OPEN DIALOGUE INCOME BETWEEN
THE AG. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF A
PESTICIDE REGULATIONS PRIOR TO-
THE DIRECTOR A SUIT IN OTHER
TORTILLA I NECESSARY AND WE
THINK WE'RE CLOSE IN THAT. IT'S
A REAL EASY FIX OUR THE BILL
HAS COME IS THE- HOT THE FINES
AND THE ENFORCEMENT GOING FROM
HOUSE TO TWENTY BUT- BE THERE
FOR ON OUR INTERPRETATION OF. A
LOT OF THESE INCIDENTS PLACER.
ARE NOT. IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
APPLICATION THESE ARE. NOT AN
EXCUSE FOR THE VIOLATION BUT
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
RAISES A CONCERN FOR US IF IT
WERE TO GO FROM A POTENTIAL
FIVE THOUSAND VERSUS A TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FIVE WHAT HAS OP.
POTENTIAL BE STACKED UP IT'S
PER BELLY WHICH- INDEED YOU
KNOW OTHER ELEMENTS ARE WITHIN
THE PRIORITY INCIDENT MEMO WITH
THE AG COMMISSIONERS ANOTHER
SOAP WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
TRIMS TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
UNDER THE CURRENT THE THOUGHT
OF FOR THESE MINDSET TOO WE
PRO. AND BE QUITE EXCESSIVE ON
IN. WE ALSO HAVE JUST TO A
LARGER CONCERN IN THAT. THE
AMOUNT OF TOOLS IN THE NUMBER
OF TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE I IN THE
STATE OR A STRING LIMITED. A WE
DO NOT HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
TOOLS THAT OTHER FARMERS WITHIN
THE COUNTRY HAVE HI WHILE WE
HAVE A VERY ROBUST DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION- THAT
ROBUSTNESS IN THOSE RULES
REALLY RESTRICT WHAT PRODUCTS
INCOME TO OF THE MARKET. THAT
NUMBER OF BIOLOGICAL PRODUCTS
UNDER NUMBER GREENER PRODUCTS
QUOTE UNQUOTE SAFETY- SAFER
PRODUCTS ARE BEING UTILIZED IN
ALL OTHER AREAS OF THE COUNTRY
THAT ARE NOT BEING UTILIZED.
BECAUSE ADDITION. BRING THE
MARKET AND THE TIMELINESS TO
BRING PRODUCTS TO THE MARKET.
AND SO WITHOUT THOSE OTHER
AVAILABLE TOOLS WE DO SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WHEN A MISTAKE
HAPPENS WHEN AN INCIDENT OCCURS
THAT THEY COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE SEVERE.
BECAUSE SOME CHEMISTRIES THAT
WE HAVE AND USE HERE- IN THE
STATE SO WE THINK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. IN A MORE IN THIS ISSUE
IN GREATER DETAIL. HOW WE KNOW
THAT OUR SOME. GROUPS ARE IN
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE RIGHT. IN THEIR
CURRENT PRACTICES. HOW WE THINK
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED
UPON AND WE NEED TO BE
ENCOURAGING THE DEPARTMENT AND
OTHERS TO BRING THESE OTHER
PRODUCTS TO MARKET- SO THAT WE
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF THIS
INCIDENTS ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. AND FOR THE PER THOSE
PURPOSES WE ARE OPPOSING
AMENDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIX WITNESSES MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MATTHEW CYBERLINK
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS AND
SEALERS ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT
APPEARS IN PRINT TODAY BUT I
JUST I HAVE TO. OF COURSE LIKE
LIKE LOUIS IN AND THE AUTHOR OF
A FIRST THE COMMITTEE STAFF I
THINK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF.
FOR CONSISTENTLY CONSTANTLY
REACHING OUT TO US TO TRY TO
GET FEEDBACK TO TRY TO. GET
THIS IN NOW WITH THE POSITIONS
BUT WE DID THAT PRIOR TO THIS
TEAM DURING. THE IN A NUT SHELL
HE- FOR THE ARTICLE TO TAKE
OVER AND INVESTIGATE. OR AYE
AYE AND IT. ACTION WITHIN THE
WOULD LIKE THAT TO SEE. TO THAT
A LITTLE BIT MORE- COOPERATIVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE- OF A JOINT
DECISION MADE BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE AYE COMMISSION I THINK.
VERY CLOSE. WITH DROPS OF A
FLOATING. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE TO FIND THOSE WORDS
THAT THAT WORK IN BECAUSE WORDS
MATTER. WHEN YOU PLACE THE LAW-
SECONDLY WE'D LIKE TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONVERSATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT. I JUST
MAKE BUT WE UNDERSTAND THE FLOW
CHART NAY INTERVIEW AND HOW AND
HOW THAT THE WHOLE PROCESS IS
GOING TO TAKE PLACE. I'M GONNA
BE COMMUNICATING WANT TO SORT
OF KNOW WITHOUT. THIS IS GONNA
BE A NEW. A NEW PROCESS. WORK
THROUGH. AND IN LASTLY I DID
BRING UP AWAY. TODAY ANY TYPE
OF QUESTIONS. THE CURRENT. UP
PROCESS AND IF YOU COULD
INTRODUCE MYSELF AND IT'S BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS IF YOU
DO HAVE ANY AYE. I'M STEVE SURE
YUBA COUNTY AG COMMISSIONER.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW M. ANYMORE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD THANK YOU YES A GOOD
AFTERNOON MATTHEW OUT WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS MADE
BY MISTER BROWN ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESS EMITTED. GOOD AFTERNOON
TAYLOR OCEAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU ERE ALSO POSED
WITH MENDED THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
C. DISSOCIATION OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY THAT RIGHT SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT UP
HERE TO THE DIE IS MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. THE
TERMINAL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SO- I THINK WE'RE ALL UNITED IN
OUR DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT-
PESTICIDES APPROPRIATELY
REGULATED IN CALIFORNIA A
COUPLE CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL
THE FIRST IS THE SIZE OF THE
PENALTY INCREASE WHEN YOU MAKE
A GOOD POINT THAT THE PENALTY
ADOPTED INCREASE YEARS IF YOU
APPLY THE AYE. TING PENALTY TO
NEAR WHAT INCREASE. IT DOES
COLBERT ABOUT WHAT IT'S A PROP
TO ONCE A INCREASE THIS PEDAL
BY FIVE TIMES. YES I TO WAKE
POINT ALSO ON AMMO SAID EARLIER
RELATED TO THE FINE SO WANNA BE
CLEAR IT'S UP TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR THERE'S JUST.
IN THAT BY ALL MEANS I. IT IS
OFTEN NOT THE CASE THAT.
MAXIMUM FOR. I'M SPEAK
CONSULTORES BY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR UNDER UNDER THE STATUTE IT
IS NOT MANDATED- BUT IT'S- AT A
COUPLE THINGS ONE IS YES IT'S A
FIVE FOLD INCREASE IN HERE'S
WHAT WAS DONE IN THE PAST IT'S
BEEN TWENTY YEARS. WE'VE SEEN
AN INCREASE BECAUSE OF IT A
LONG TIME BUT YOU'RE RIGHT. I'M
YOU COULD YOU SEE PEOPLE. COME
THE SAME. I'M WE INTO THIS
NUMBER IN PART BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OTHER SECTIONS OF. IT'S
KIND OF REGULATORY CODE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
SIMILAR TO THOSE IT'S LOWER
THAN A LOT OF OTHERS AS- NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND IT SEEMS
LIKE THE- BREAD. A MAXIMUM
PENALTY TO SURE WE HAVE THE
TOOLS TO PREVENT THESE.
INCIDENTS WHEN THERE ARE
PRAIRIE INCIDENT SO AGAIN ONLY
FOCUSED ON THE ROAD THE
INCIDENTS ARE CAUSING. AB HAVE
BLURRED TOOLBOX. BY THE LAW.
OKAY THANK YOU IN MY SECOND
CONCERN. REGARDS THE APPEARANCE
SO WHERE YOU'RE SURFING LOCAL
CONTROL HERE AND I KNOW I
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT
I KNOW MANY OF US DID- I ALWAYS
KIND OF RESENTED IT WHEN THE
STATE CAME IN AND TOLD ME THAT
I WE WERE DOING. OF THE STATE
WAS GONNA COME WILL TAKE
CONTROL AND I'M WONDERING
THOUGH IS THAT WHY YOU'RE DOING
THIS BECAUSE WE FOR THE LOCAL
AGENT AREN'T DOING ENOUGH.
HELLO THESE THESE ABUSES PASSED
ASIDE USE. OR IT A NO IT'S
SEEMS. YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE IS
THE OVERRIDING REASON WHY. DPR
NEEDS TO COME AND TAKE THIS
AUTHORITY. YES SO LET'S. NOT
TAKING IT AND I AM THANK YOU
BOTH FOR BEING HERE AND IN IN
MANY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ACT.
THERE ISN'T VERY CLOSE TO THEM.
BUT YOU KNOW TIME IT I MEAN WE
DIDN'T GET TO THE LANGUAGE BUT
I. THINK I'M ALSO CONFIDENT
WE'LL GET BASE WHERE THE
COUNTRY. SO I KNOW MEANS. AWAY
FROM THEM. I MEAN THAT'S THE
GOAL. THEY WOULD BE THIS
CLUSTER. OFF I BELIEVE IF WE
WERE. BUT YOU CAN SPEAK FOR
ITSELF AND BUT I THINK THAT
THAT THE NASA SAYS HE DOES
COMES IN A COUPLE WAYS WHAT IS.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE GROUP.
SECTION BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
WITH A SPRAY. AND IN THOSE
CASES MAKING SURE THAT IS AN
AUTHORITY THAT CAN DO IT. MAKES
SENSE BUT ALSO WHERE THE COUNTY
COMMISSIONERS. ARE FOR WHATEVER
REASON CONFLICTED OUT OR
OTHERWISE IF THEY'RE NOT.
APPROPRIATE AND HEATED DUET
THIS GIVES. DEEP TO DO IT IN
LIEU OF THAT BUT THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE ARE CLOSE TO ADDING.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE IT THERE
SO I CAN'T GIVE YOU EXACT
LANGUAGE BUT- RELATES THIS KIND
OF COLLABORATION AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE LOCAL AUTHORITY AND
IF YOU ARE THAT THEY ARE THE
APPROPRIATE. ENTITY TO DO IT.
LOOKING TO. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
OKAY BUT THAT'S A REALLY.
IMPORTANT YEAH I THINK. BECAUSE
IF THE PR IS GONNA TAKE OVER AN
INVESTIGATION. I THINK IT THAT
HAS TO BE THE REASON. YEAH THAT
THAT BECAUSE IT'S MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL. BUT THEY'RE THE
MOST. CREATION AND THAT I THINK
WOULD REQUIRE. ROB OF THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS. ON
A LOCAL LEVEL SO. I'M GLAD TO
HEAR YOU SAY THAT- I'LL BE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TODAY
BUT- THAT COULD CHANGE. IF AND
WHEN YOU TAKE THAT AND WHICH
BECAUSE IT'S REAL IMPORTANT ME.
THANK YOU. I THINK THIS ONE I
THINK THE- OTHER FOR CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE WE'VE
BEEN. TRYING TO FIX THIS FOR A
WHILE WE HAVE A HISTORY HERE SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I'M ADDING
CURRENT THE OPPOSITION STATE
TABLE THE COMMITTEE HAS WORKED
HARD AND WE THOUGHT WE HAD A
DEAL. I'M WITH THAT I WANT TO
MAKE. SEC. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. NO OKAY SO THIS
BILL IS- IDENTICAL TO THE BILL
THAT CAME TWO YEARS AGO BY OUR
CHAIRMAN- WHICH FAILED ON THE
FLOOR. AND LIKELY WILL FAIL
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP TODAY BY MY
COLLEAGUES THE LARGE INCREASE
IN THE FINE THE TAKING AWAY
LOCAL CONTROL BE CONCERNED THAT
DOWN THE STATE MIGHT COME STEP%
IN WHERE HER. CLOTHES DECIDE NO
ACTION IS WARM AND IN THE STATE
DECIDES TO COMMAND AND SAID NOW
WE THINK ACTION IS WARRANTED
NOT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE GIVES.
GREAT BURNING TURN ON SO THAT
BEING AND I HOPE THAT ALONG THE
WAY. ALL CAN COME TO SORT OF
REMEMBER CENTER THIS BILL SAY
IN THE POINT I CAN'T WAIT FOR
THE VERY SAME MANIC FOR A LOT
TIME. I HAVE A LOT. I AM BUT
THE END RESULT OF THIS BILL
WOULD BE EXACTLY THAT TIME WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I LET YOU
KNOW THAT I'M I'M WITH YEAH. AS
FAR AS MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE HARMED BY PASSED FINDS BUT
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
DONE IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T ALSO
HARM THE INDUSTRY SO. ON
THERE'S MOTION SIR. I'M SICK.
THIS IS ITEM ONE AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN. BAUER-KAHAN THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
MELENDEZ NOW. MELENDEZ NO
-ARAMBULA. BAUER-KAHAN HI CAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
MATHIS WHAT A TO G. MURATSUCHI
HI OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO KALRA
KALRA HI. FIVE TWO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT BILL IS OUT- THE
FINAL BILL WE HAVE ON THE
AGENDA TODAY IS ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. TWO ZERO SIX ZERO BY
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDING MOVE THE
BILL. THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR
TO MOVE THE BILL. **** IT ALL
RIGHT THERE IN THE SECOND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
HOLDEN PERCEIVE WHEN YOU'RE
READY. BECAUSE OF THE SERVER
BODE WELL MEDIC HERE THANK YOU
AND MEMBERS- I LOOK FORWARD TO
REBEL RESPONSE ON AB TWENTY
SIXTY CURRENT LAW ESTABLISHES A
CONTENT STANDARD OF POINT TWO
FIVE LET PERCENT LEAD FOR
PLUMBING FIXTURES TO APPLY WITH
THE LEAD PRETTY STANDARD. LAST
YEAR IN A INTERNET IT'LL TESTED
FIVE HUNDRED FAUCETS THAT MET
THE CALIFORNIA LEAD CONTENT
STANDARD AND FOUND THE 25% OF
THE FAUCETS TESTED LEACH NOTICE
NOTICEABLY. AMOUNTS OF LET. AB
TWENTY SIXTY WOULD ESTABLISH A
LEAD LEACHING PERFORMANCE
STANDARD TO COMPLY AS LEAD FREE
IT WOULD REQUIRE IN USE
FIXTURES TO LEAD TO LESS THAN
ONE MILLIGRAM LEADER LEADER LET.
WE ALL EXPECT THE WATER WE
DRINK WILL BE CAP. WILL KEEP US
HEALTHY AND NOT MAKE A SICK
HELLO IT HAS BEEN WORKING TO
REDUCE RESIDENTS EXPOSURE TO
LEAD YET LET IS STILL LIBERTINE
AND OR DRINKING WATER THROUGH
FAUCETS AND FIXTURES REQUIRE
ALL FAUCETS AND FIXTURES.
LEECHES LITTLE LEAD AS POSSIBLE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M JOINED HERE AS-
WITH MY WITNESSES TODAY TOM NET
MILLER MILLER. CHEMICAL POLICY
YEAH YES ALL RIGHT. WE'VE KNOWN
EACH OTHER SO LONG CHEMICAL
POLICY DIRECTOR OF ANIMAL
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUSAN LITTLE SENIOR ADVOCATE
FOR CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP. I APPRECIATE THIS TIME
DOLLAR WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND I APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR PRESENTING
AVAIL- WE RISE IN SUPPORT OF
IT. UP I'VE WORKED ON LEAD
POISONING PREVENTION FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS BUT DRINKING WATER
FOR THE PAST SIX AND OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THEY HAVE
WORKED WITH THE NSF
INTERNATIONAL COMMITTEE THE
NATIONAL SANITATION FOUNDATION
COMMITTEE. THAT HANDLES THE-
THE STANDARD THAT'S LIMITS THE
AMOUNT OF LET BE LEACHED ERA
CAN LAMBERT OF LEAD TO COMPETE
IN DEFAULT IT'S AN BE LEAKED
OUT. I NEED TWO YEAR AND TRYING
AGAIN FOR THIRD. THE TITANS
STANDARDS AND THIS YEAR THERE
IS A CONSENSUS AROUND MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE MANDATORY
STANDARDS AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT LATER. I
DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THAT. SAYS
MOVING TO SETS LIMITS AND THEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT TO FOLLOW
THROUGH BECAUSE THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE. WE START THIS TAP
GROUP AND THEN IT TO GO TO A
COMMITTEE AND THEN IT GOES
PROPOSED PROCESS. THE THREE.
HELPS TO. ASSIST HAPPENS. CAN.
THANK MY NAME IS SUSAN LITTLE
I'M WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP AND THEY'RE
BERMAN WORKING GROUP WAS THE
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY WITH ALSO AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN SEVERAL
YEARS AGO REQUIRES CHILD CARE
CENTERS TO TEST THE KING WILL
FOR LEAD AND AS AFTER THAT BILL
WAS ENACTED WE HAVE BEEN SINCE
THAT TIME WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICE. AND
THE WATER. IMPLEMENTING THAT
BILL. FOR WHICH THAT THE
TESTING IS ALREADY BEGINNING-
IN IN THE COURSE OF DEVELOPING-
HELPING WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WITH THE BOARD
ON DEVELOPING THE GUIDELINES OF
THE DIRECTIVES FROM THIS
PROGRAM- WE COME CAME ACROSS
THIS CUT. DRUM DEALING WITH
SETS WERE IF THE CHILD CARE
CENTERS. A MANY OF WHICH ARE IN
PRE OR AN OLDER BUILDINGS.
DISCOVER THAT FOSTER. DOUBLE
DECKERS HI MENTAL BUT IN THERE
WHAT. STE GO TO YOU FOR. XIN
WILL BE THE TO REMOVE. WHICH
FAUCET. FIND BUT DESPITE.
WORKING WITH THE ENVIRONMENT
FUND. THAT IT'S ACTUALLY POP
THAT THE REPLACE FOR THAT THEY
WOULD PURCHASE AND THEN INSTALL
COULD ACTUALLY LEACH RIGHT NOW
UNDER CURRENT STANDARDS MORE
LEAD. THAN THE FAUCET THAT THEY
WOULD BE SWITCHING OUT. AND SO-
IN AND OUR EFFORT TO TRY TO
HELP THE CENTERS AND SCHOOLS
WERE ALSO FACING THE THING
CONUNDRUM. IDENTIFIED THEM
FAUCETS THAT LEAD THE LEAGUE
LEACH LEAST OF LEAD WE- STARTED
DISINVEST CAME A WHAT IS WHAT
IS HAPPENED HOW ARE THESE
FAUCETS WE KNOW THEY'RE BETTER
PERFORMING FAUCETS OUT THERE
HOW CAN WE IDENTIFY THOSE AND
FOUND THAT THERE'S REALLY NO
WAY TO DO THAT WE CAN'T
IDENTIFY. CONSUMER THEY ARE
USUALLY. WHICH ARE THE BEST
FORMING. WE KNOW QUITE IF. NOT
TO IT'S A WHICH THIS VERY LOW
AMOUNT LEAD AND SO THAT THE
GENESIS OF THIS BILL AND- WE
FOR WE- ARE VERY PLEASED THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN WANTED
TO ENTERED WANTED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PROPOSAL. AND
WE ANTICIPATE ENACTMENT OF THE
BILL WILL NOT ONLY HELP THE
CHILD CARE CENTERS ENSURE THAT
THEIR DRINKING WATER. AS LATE
AS POSSIBLE ON IT IN THE
SCHOOLS AS WELL BUT EVENTUALLY
THE GENERAL POP CALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE BETTER POSITS SO WE WOULD
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHOOSE
ANYONE ELSE WITH WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GO AHEAD.
STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS ASAP FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND CALPERS IN
SUPPORT. DAPHNE MACKLIN ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT. JIM
WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. GRACE WESTER HOUSE-
GROUP UNIFIED DISTRICT I DON'T
WANT THAT IN MY WATER. SLIP
AWAY HELLO. ELK GROVE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I WANT
CLEAN WATER. LILIANA WESTER HAS
EL GROW UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ADDED I WON'T CLEAN WATER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LADIES GOOD
JOB- OKAY ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT NOW OKAY
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
TWEENER A TWEENER OUR RATE WILL
TAKE BETWEEN YEARS. OKAY.
AFTERNOON JERRY DOESN'T I'M
REPRESENTING PLUMBING
MANUFACTURES INTERNATIONAL OR
PMI HAVE ABOUT FORTY DIFFERENT
COMPANIES ACROSS THE NATION THE
MANUFACTURERS PRODUCE
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF A PUTTING
PRODUCTS SOLD IN THE UNITED
STATES IN CALIFORNIA THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DIFFERENT NAME
BRAND. A AS WELL WITH THE OFFER
IS THE BOTTOM OF OPPOSITE. THAT
THE TO BEGIN WITH APPRECIATE
BUT THE SEVEN MEMBER HOLDEN AND
THE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS ARE
CAPTION WITH AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION THERE.
AND THE GOAL OF PROVIDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE CENTERS IN A WE
EMBRACE AND SUPPORT COMPLETELY
EFFECT PM I IN THE MEMBER
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
SINCE THE DIPLOMAT CHEN OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES. THAT A STEP
BY STEP LEVELS FOR FAUCETS BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX AND WE WERE
COMMENT THAT IT'S THAT A TO GET
PRODUCTS OUT OF. PLACE TO WE'VE
ENGAGED IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SUMMER HOLDEN IN HIS OFFICE
IN THE- SPONSORS AND ORDER. TO
OF THE TO READ THE DIALOGUE
FORD IF I COULD TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE ISSUES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE THE WILL
COME BEFORE THE LARGEST. WE YOU
KNOW PRODUCTIVE PERCEPTIONS AND
WERE CONSCIOUS OF THE SLICK AND
VICIOUS YOU KNOW THAT THAT WILL
OCCUR. AND THE FIRST THE BILL
AS OF INTENT. THIS IS MORE THAN
JUST CARE CENTERS. AT THE PLOT
PRODUCTS INTENT. CAPTION THROB
STATE THE TO BRING IN THE THEM
OF GETTING THEM CERTIFIED AND
BRING THEM TO MARKET IT TAKES
ALL TIME AND A FIGHT REFER BABY
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE BY FORMER
CHAD IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THERE
WAS A THREE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION
PERIOD THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE
TOUR FOR THIS BILL EVER SO
BRING IT IN THOSE KINDS OF
CONVERSATION. DOVE TAIL AND A
SET THE SUIT WITH IF YOU VALUE
ONE AT THE FED. TALKING ABOUT
IT JANUARY ON TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR PUT. SETH IS COME INTO THE
CONVERSATION AS ONE OF THE SORT
OF FIRES AND A COUPLE. OF THE
FIRST CASE ABOUT THE TAKES
RECERTIFY YOUR PRODUCTS AT THE
FAMILY PRODUCTS TO LOOK AT HOW
MANY THE THEIR FIFTY THOUSAND
FAUCETS THAT ARE ON THE- IN THE
MARKET TODAY AND THEN TO BRING
UP INTO. A SUCCESSFUL FOR. YOU
REALLY HOW SAFE WATER YOU DON'T
GET THE RESULTS THAT ARE
FINDING IS REPLACED. UP SECOND
IS WE LOOK AT THE AFTER AND THE
IMMEDIATE DILEMMA THAT IS US
WE'RE TRYING TO SEE WHAT DO YOU
WITH THE- BOSS SUPPORTERS TO A
THAT. THEY SHOULD. AT THE TABLE
THAT THE ANA SUBTESTS GROUP ARE
PARTICIPATING CAN WE MOVE THAT
ISSUE FORWARD FOR QUICKER
ADOPTION OF AN ASSET SIXTY ONE
THE QUEUE VALUE ONE. SO THAT'LL
DRIVE THE COMPETITIVE MARKET
AND OUR MEMBERS ARE COMPETITORS
TO TRY TO PROVIDE THAT PRODUCT
BUT IT'S A CERTIFIED PRODUCT.
SO IS THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN
GET TO THAT GOAL. A THAT. IT'S
THE IT'S A PRODUCTS EVER
COMMITTED TO WORKING. FOR THE
BILL AND TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE OFF TO A GOOD
START AND WE'RE- AT THE- OKAY
VERY MUCH ANYWAY ELSE IS A
TWEENER OR IN OPPOSITE. NOW
OKAY OVER HERE TO THE DIS
MEMBERS ANYONE BECAUSE DOCTOR
EMILY REFERS. TO GO. I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE I GOT THAT FIGURE
RIGHT DID YOU SAY THAT TWO
THIRDS OF THE REPLACEMENT
FAUCETS HAVE LED IN THEM NOW.
TWO THIRDS OF THEM NOW WOULD
PASS THE TEST IS WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING. TWO THIRDS OF THE
BOSSES OUT THERE NOW ARE FINE
AND- WITHIN REGULATION AND THE
REPLACEMENT ONES THAT YOU WERE
MENTIONING THAT ALSO WERE.
HAVING LET. WHAT WAS THAT
PERCENTAGE. TO BE CLEAR THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW YET HOW MANY
REPLACEMENT FAUCETS WILL BEING
HOW MAY CHILD CARE CENTERS WE
NEED TO REPLACE THEIR FAUCET
SCHOOLS TO DATE HAVE ABOUT 18%
OF THE FOSTER TESTED AT SCHOOLS
HAVE HAD TO BE REPLACED- SOME
SPECULATION THAT WE COULD BE
LOOKING AT AM ARM NUMBER FOR
CHILD CARE. I DON'T KNOW THAT.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS ON BASED NSF
TASTE TESTING. THAT
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED WELL
UPDATED IT TESTING THEY TESTED
ABOUT APPROXIMATE FIVE HUNDRED
FAUCETS. FOR THEIR LEACHING
VALUE AND FOUND THAT 73% OF THE
TO THOSE TESTS SHOWED THAT THE
FAUCETS. HAD ON THE- BEACH THE
LEAST AMOUNT UNDER THE- UNDER
THE ONE MICROGRAM. PER LITER OF
LEAD WHICH IS THE KEY WHAT ONE
WHICH- TECHNICAL I KNOW BUT-
AND BASED ON THE STING. WE
PROJECT AT ABOUT 252725% OF THE
FAUCETS ON THE MARKET TODAY
EVEN THOUGH THEY MEET THE
CONTENT STANDARD FOR LAD THAT
IS YOU KNOW THE METAL STATE.
THEY'RE PERFECT AND HEARD THE
MOUNT THAT THE LEECH IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE IT'S MORE
THAN- THE QUEUE OF ONE AND IN
SOME CASES MUCH HIGHER AND TOM
WHO HAS. GREAT HAS STUDY THOSE
THOSE TESTS COULD PROBABLY
EXPLAIN THAT MORE. WELL I THINK
MY POINT IS I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY AND
I THINK THIS IS A ANOTHER
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD THERE'S
NO AMOUNT OF LEAD THAT SAFE FOR
CHILDREN. AND SO WHY ARE THESE
FAUCET IN THE MARKET. IF THEY
HAVE A NUMBER WHICH IS HIGHER
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND. WHY IS A QUARTER
OF THE MARKET STILL. LEACHING
LEAD AT A LEVEL THAT'S
DETECTABLE WHEN THERE'S NO
STATE FROM FOR KIDS. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
REALLY DIG INTO AND FIGURE OUT
AND MAYBE YEAH MY APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
BUT- FELT LIKE IT WAS A POOR.
BUT THE DIAL SURE SURE. BUT
THERE. THERE MIGHT BE SOME IN
TERMS OF THE STUDY THAT WAS
CONDUCTED AND OVER ENGAGE IN
THAT CONVERSATION WITH NSF AND
THE STUFF OF WHICH THEY WERE
HERE AT THE TABLE AS THE
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY SORT OF
OUR WHAT- I'M- PLAYING IT I
THINK A RECESSION WAS THAT WHEN
YOU Q. VALUE ONE IT'S THERE'S A
RANGE THAT'S THE TO THERE'S
ONLY. FIGHT TO SO IT'S NOT THAT
MARKETED. YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT
MARKETED AT THAT LEVEL BUT IT'S
WHAT THEY THOUGHT THEY FOUND.
IN THE TESTING THAT OF DEAD BUT
THEY SAID IT'S BEING TAKEN OUT
OF CONTEXT TO SAY THAT THERE'S
THAT MUCH COMPLY THAT THERE'S
THAT PERCENTAGE OF INDUSTRY
COMPLY. THE SECOND IS THERE IS
ACT. I THINK IT'S A PLUMBING
BUT SECTIONS. FORTY ONE OF
TITLE TWENTY FOUR THE ACTUALLY
PUTS THE CURRENT AND A SUB
STANDARD IN THERE AND THEN. WE
TO WE'RE LOOKING AT LEACH RATE
SUPPOSED CON. SO THEY'RE
DIFFERENT MEASURE OF. PLACE WE-
BUT WITH SO. WHAT UP THERE
SHOULD BE SAFE IF NOT SO FOR
THE- WE HAVE TO DO SOME ABOUT
IT THE- YOU KNOW WE DO WE NOT
WE DO NOT A- THAT. IF YOU WERE
TO REPLACE A FAULT IN THIS
TODAY THAT YOU CAN GET A HIGHER
LEVEL THAN A TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD FAUCET. NO JUST LOOK AT
THAT THE I THINK IT'S HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE ONE SIXTY NEED
SEVENTY FIVE STATUS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. DODGE IS A
MAXIMUM. OF FOUR MORE FOR THE
MAXIM LEAD CONTENT IN ANY
FAUCET. SO THE NEW FALL TO THE
UP LEACH. THE LITTLE FAUCET IS
NOT A TITLE. DURATION. OKAY
MIKE. I COULD ADD THAT. WITH WE
DID TESTING IN CHILDCARE
CENTERS. AND WE FOUND THAT
INDEED SOME OF THEM WE ACTUALLY
HAD MEMBERS THAT WENT OFF THAT
WAY HI AFTER WE REPLACE THE
FAUCET. MOST OF THE BOSSES WERE
IN GOOD SHAPE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO IDENTIFY
THE THAT PERFORM WELL VERSUS
ONES THAT. HELLO I ACTUALLY
LIKE TO TUNNEL DOWN ON
SOMETHING THAT DOCTOR ROOM
YOU'LL JUST JUST MENTIONED AND
THAT'S THE YOU KNOW THIS
DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR LEAD IN
WATER BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW IT I
THINK WE'RE UNIFIED OUR DESIRE
TO MAKE SURE THAT CHILDREN ARE
HARMED BUT IT'S ALSO.
COMPLETELY WRONG SAY THAT
ANYTHING COULD BE LEAD FREE
FROM A LOCAL STANDPOINT OTHERS
LET AT. THINGS WILL LEAD MY CAN
CAUGHT BUDGET A VERY LOW
CONCENTRATIONS IN A WEEK WE
ENFORCE STANDARDS THAT SAY THAT
NO HERE PART OF. FARM FULL
KNOWN TO OUR FOR. WE DON'T. ANY
MORE THAN YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT
THAT'S NOT HARMFUL SO. MY
QUESTION IS THEN. YOU KNOW THE
CURRENT NATIONAL STANDARD IS
ONE IS FIVE MICROGRAMS PER
LITER. AND I WOULD LOOK FOR
SOME PEER REVIEWED RESEARCH
THAT SAYS THAT. ONE MICROGRAM
PER LEADER IS SAFER FOR
CHILDREN THAN FIVE MICROGRAMS
PER LITER AND I COULDN'T FIND
ANY SO I'M WONDERING IF THAT'S
THAT HAS READ THAT RESEARCH
BEEN DONE BECAUSE I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MAKE DECISIONS
ON A- ON THE BASIS OF
SCIENTIFIC. STUDY AND JUST
AFTER. YEAH YOUR YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL IN
OUR GOAL THAT WAS TO DRIVE THE
LEVELS DOWN BECAUSE LET IS FOR
BROWN JUST SITS IN THE SOIL
IT'S IN THE PAINT. AND IT'S
AND- IT'S IN THE WATER VICTIMS
CAN I CHALLENGE YOU TO DO ON
THAT THERE'S NO SAFE LEVEL.
EXPO TO LEAD THAT WE'VE EVERY
TIME WE'VE LOOKED WE FIND THAT
THERE'S HAZARDS. TO CHILDREN
AND EVEN TO ADULTS AT LOW
LEVELS. THAT LOWER LOWER LOWER
THAN FIVE MICROGRAMS PER LITER.
YES YES OF MY CAN GIVE AN
EXAMPLE IS FDA APPROVED DRUG
ADMINISTRATION SAYS THAT THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF CHILD SHOULD
BE EXPOSED TO IN A DAY IS THREE
MICROGRAMS. WELL IN THAT FIRST
QUARTER LEADER SAMPLE THAT THE
SCHOOL STATE TAKE THAT'S THREE
PARTS PER BILLION SO. JUST
FIFTY IT'S IT WOULD EXCEED A
SINGLE SAMPLE THAT FIVE WOULD
EXCEED FDA OR FTA ZONE IF THE
CHILD DRANK A LITER OF WATER
FROM THE FAUCET. WORTHY JUST
DRINK A QUARTER LEADER OF WATER
THAT HAD THAT FIGHT ON THAT
AMOUNT IN IT- BECAUSE THE
STANDARDS BASED ON FIVE
MICROGRAMS OF LEAD IN A- IN
THAT WATER THE CUT PASSES
THROUGH THE FAUCET. THE ONES
THAT WERE CERTIFIED. NINE
MICROGRAMS IN THAT FIRST
SAMPLE. SO MUCH HIGHER LEVEL
SURE BUT I MEAN THE NATIONAL
STANDARD IS FIVE. RIGHT SO THAT
THAT THAT'S NOT COMPLIANT WITH
THE CURRENT NATIONAL STANDAR
IF IT AT THIRTY ONE MICROGRAMS
BELIEVE WAS CERTIFIED UNDER THE
CURRENT STAND. BECAUSE IT'S
AVERAGED OVER THREE WEEKS OF.
TESTING SO THE FOR VERY FIRST
APPLES WERE THE NINE BUT THE OF
MY DOWN QUICKLY RIGHT SO WITH
AVERAGE TO BELOW. THE DOOR THE
ONE WOULD MAKE IT. INTO THE-
WOODS OUT THAT WAY. THAT THOSE
FOSTER UNEXAMPLED THAT WOULD BE
FREE TO I UNDERSTAND WHY AM I.
YEAH I WANNA BE'S OF. BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAKING AND FOR TO. YEAH I'M TO
SAY. THERE SHALL BE NO LEFT IN
ANYTHING IS NOT. SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE EVER GOING TO ACHIEVE AT
AND I'M JUST A VERY CARDS
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT OTHER. ISSUES
THAT COME BEFORE THIS IS LIKE A
HEXAVALENT CHROMIUM UNDER WATER
WHICH IS NATURALLY OCCURRING
DOESN'T HAVE BECOME FROM
CONTAMINATION. AND TO SAY EVERY
TIME THAT WE- ARE DETECTION
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES AND WE'RE
GOING LOWER THE STANDARD. A BIT
IN EVIDENCE YOU KNOW IT IS NOT
THE- TO. JUST BECAUSE WE ENDED.
LEFT AT LOWER. DOESN'T KNOW.
MEAN THAT THE STANDARD OF THE
LAW SO IF YOU WOULD PLEASE IF
YOU COULD- THEM FROM THAT THE
STUDIES THAT YOU HAVE IF YOU
CAN GET THOSE TOMORROW SO I
COULD REVIEW MIGHT REALLY BE
PURGED OF THE FIGHTER. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. NO OKAY
WELL. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE FOR POINTING OUT SOME
OF THINGS THAT I WAS ACTUALLY
THINKING BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
DANGEROUS TO SUGGEST THAT
THERE'S SOME- THAT THERE ARE.
HIGH LEVELS OF LEAD THAT EXIST
WHERE THEY MAY NOT ACTUALLY
EXIST AND IT'S TRUE THAT.
EXPOSURE TO LEAD IS NOT HEALTHY
BUT WE DO HAVE LEAD IN VARIOUS
FORMS IN OUR ENVIRONMENT
WHETHER IT'S IN THE PIPES THAT
ARE BRINGING OUR CHECKING WATER.
OR IN THE BILL. I DON'T LIKE TO
HEAR THINGS THAT SOUND ALARMIST
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CERTAINLY- CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE ALLOWING OUR CHILDREN TO
INGESTION YOU KNOW EVERYONE
ELSE WHO'S EXPOSED TO IT AS
WELL- MR HOLDEN I AM WONDERING
IS THERE ANY PRIEST BUILT INTO
THIS BILL TO ALLOW MANY FACTORS
OF SEVENTIES POP THE ABILITY.
OUT OF. THE INVENTORY THAT THEY
HAVE IN REPLACE IT WITH
INVENTORY THAT MEETS THE NEW.
WHAT WILL LIKELY BE THE NEW
STANDARD. WELL I THINK THAT THE
REASON THERE'S A RECOGNITION
THAT WERE THEY WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING THE ISSUES IN GOOD
FAITH IS TRYING TO GET TO A
PLACE THIS TYPE OF CONCERNS CAN
BE MITIGATED AT CONF AND THE
RIGHT. SPOT IT SHOULD BE. BUT
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT
AGREE SPIRIT OR EXIST IF THIS
BILL PASSES AND IS IN A BIT
SIGNED INTO LAW IS IT IMMEDIATE.
WELL IN TERMS OF THE IF THAT'S
ONE OF THE ISSUES IS ON THE
TABLE I THINK THAT THAT'S THE
BOOK THE GRACE PERIOD YES THESE
ARE PART OF DISAGREEING WITH
EVERYBODY THAT IN IT AND IF
I'VE GOT IT RIGHT AS WELL. BUT
THE LEGISLATURE CURRENTLY
DRAFTED. THE COMMITTEE HAS
pENOUGH IS SILENT ON THE
EFFECTIVE DATE SO WOULD BE
GENERALLY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. BUT THE GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONS SO FAR HAVE.
FOCUSED ON A POTENTIAL JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
MANDATORY ALL PRODUCTS MUST
MEET QW ONE. AND OUR INDUSTRY
LEAVES THAT THAT WOULD PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TIME. OF FOUR BOB.
IN GETTING TO MARKET THAT WOULD
ALSO INCLUDE THE SO THAT WOULD
BE ON THE SHELVES AT ALL THE
HOME DEPOTS AND LOWS AND RIGHT
AND SO THAT'S PART OF THAT DATE
IS THAT CONSIDERATION WELL
THAT'S AND THAT'S WERE WERE
STILL IN. CONVERSATION TO GET
TO THAT WHAT WE WILL BE THE
RIGHT. SO IS THERE A CERTAIN
POINT THE DATE OR IS A STICKING
POINT FOR YOU JUST PUTTING A
GRACE PERIOD IN PLACE AT ALL.
WELL IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES
THERE MAY BE. OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE WORKING ON AND TRY TO TIE
UP LOOSE ENDS ON BUT THAT
CERTAIN THE ONE THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP IS ONE OF THE- ITEMS
THAT WE'RE- TRYING TO. PAY UP.
THE COMMON GROUND. OKAY I ASK
BECAUSE I COULD SUPPORT THE
BILL IF I KNEW. THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE SOMETHING IN PLACE
AT ALL SEE INDUSTRY TO. ADAPT
TO IN STANDARD AND NOT GET
STUCK WITH INVENTORY THAT. KING
OF SON. FINANCE HIT I AM ON DAY
ONE. TO IN A REPLACEMENT
PRODUCTS ON THE SHELVES BUT
THAT DOES TAKE TIME. TO RATHER
THAN HIT THEM WITH THAT ALL AT
ONCE IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE.
A MORE FAIR APPROACH TO I
UNDERGRADUATE. AND I DON'T. YOU
KNOW. THAT'S THE STICKING RIGHT
ME THAT'S WHAT. DURING I CAN
PRESENT A SERIOUS EFFORT OR IS
IT. NO NO NO IT'S A SIR SIR I
MEAN LOOK THIS BILL IS IN PLACE
WHERE WE WERE PRESENTED BILL
BECAUSE AND- SERVICE OF
IMPLEMENTING. SPILL IN AND
MAKING SURE. IN WATER. WORKS IS
TO LEAD FREE AS POSSIBLE OR
AROUND OUR OUR CHILDREN'S MERCY
THE ARBIL THAT WAS FOCUSING.
THE UPPER. FLOORS AT. THE DATA
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT AT THAT
TIME WAS REFLECTING HOW THE
BRAIN WAS DEVELOPING HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS. TO REALLY
GOOD AT IT SO THAT WE WERE
DOING IT AND IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL WE
DETERMINED THAT THERE WAS SOME
OTHER ISSUES AROUND FOSTER.
NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED SO WE
ARE. MOVING QUICKLY TO TRY TO
ADDRESS IT BUT AS WE MOVE
QUICKLY WE'RE BEING THOUGHTFUL
TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS HAD
BEEN BROUGHT UP FROM THE
INDUSTRY IN TRYING TO WORK
WITH. THEM TO ACCOMMODATE THE
CONCERNED. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
NOT COMPROMISE WHAT WE WANT TO.
MAKE SURE IS DONE AND THAT IS
HAVE THESE FAUCETS- CHANGED OUT
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW. THREE YEARS FOUR
YEARS OF CHILDREN DRINKING OR
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO LEAD
COMING OUT OF THE FAUCETS. IS
PART- MITIGATE TRYING. WELL WE
WANT. ME YEAH. WELL IT'S GOOD
AT JUST DATA THEY'VE GOT A
GREEN- BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WHAT WE REALIZE AND THAT'S
WHERE THE DISCUSSION I THINK IF
WE ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS CHILD
CARE CENTER SPECIFICALLY. MAYBE
IT'S A DEAL IT OF THE THEN WE
HAVE A DEADLINE AND WE ARE
DRESSING SO MAYBE THAT'S- THE
CALM PATIENT. BUT ANOTHER THAT
WE PLACE IN OTHERS ONCE THAT
SERVE CUBA ASSIST. WILL DRIVE A
CAR. MARKET AND- WHEN THERE'S A
PERSON WE'RE TO BUT THE TOP.
AND HIS GROUP. PMI IN OUR GROUP.
THIS UP THAT STANDARD. KLAY IF
THE AND IF THERE'S A WAY TO.
QUICKSTEP IT AND THAT'S WHAT
THE CHILD CARE CENTERS PURCHASE
TO. THAT'LL SMALLER MARKET.
MAYBE H. DO IT AB HE SAID. STEP
PRESS ALTHOUGH THE A
CERTIFICATE IN TOMORROW ISSUE
THAT'S LATER ON SO THAT CLOSE
GUESS TODAY. OKAY TELL YOU WHAT
I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO. I AM HOPE
THAT WE SEE SOME CHANGES ALONG
THE WAY WERE YOU ALL CAN GET
TOGETHER HAMMER AT SOME OF
THESE DETAILS ABOUT THE- GET TO
THE POINT HE GETS A FOUR. I
DON'T. WELL TO GET. ONE AT
MINIMUM RATE BUT- DO YOU THINK
IT'S ONLY FAIR TO THE INDUSTRY
TO ALLOW THEM AT LEAST TIME TO
ADJUST. THAT THERE IS A MOTION
AND A SECOND SO MADAM SECRETARY
TO PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE. THIS
IS IT. AB TWENTY SIX HE HOLDEN
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MELENDEZ HI MOM
BYE -ARAMBULA -ARAMBULA I BY
OUR- CAN I. NAY GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HIGH
MATHIS MATHIS I WOULD HAVE TO
GI OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
KALRA. CALLER I WE HAVE A
UNANIMOUS VOTE THAT COUNTS AND
WHILE THAT HAPPEN VERY OFTEN
CONGRADULATIONS- OKAY SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR WE
HAVE. NO ADAM. WE HAVE A COUPLE
MEMBERS IT TO ADD ON FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY IS IT ON
YEAH IT'S ON I'M THIS IS SET
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AT
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE -ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I HOLDEN. CHRIS YES
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HOLDEN. I MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MATTEUCCI WHAT'S THE GI WE HAVE
ONE MORE AB NINETEEN NINETY OR
CAN WE HAVE AN ADD ON VOTE I'VE
TO MATHIS. MATH NOW IRATE
LUTHER BUSINESS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE. YOU ARE WELCOME AND
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.